talk to me
I said talk to me damn it all right
make you talk
I said talk to me damn it or else I'm
gonna throw you in the fire
[Music]
all right did you [ __ ] with me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my God
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
let's go I'll go first stay right behind
me
[Music]
all right
come on
wait give me your hands
[Music]
little bastard
[Music]
hurry
you can't get away from me
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
bells and bonds headed south on the
stronger than expected economic data
which served to both for the U.S dollar
the dollar Index up a quarter point is
the RV index up to 143 at 2 30.
revealing help from crude oil March
crude up 32 cents
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
hey
[Music]
want to play Hey wanna play I like to be
hugged I like to be hugged hi my name is
Larry hi my name is Polly hey wanna play
Hey wanna play I like to be
[Music]
[Music]
don't [ __ ] with the chuck
oh my God
oh
my
God
bullseye
[Music]
laughs
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
just like the good old days nothing like
a strangulation to get the circulation
going
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we belong yet
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
awake
[Music]
what a Croc
foreign
foreign
and if you know what's good for you you
are going to love honor and obey I
wouldn't marry you if you had the body
of GI Joe hey Raggedy Ann you looked in
the mirror lately now's not the time to
get picky
sorry
just messing with you
what time is it
we're gonna have our old boys night out
just you and me how does that sound
where are we going
hunting
[Music]
I can't see anything
maybe we should slow down no you're
doing great
[Applause]
son of a [ __ ]
up yours [ __ ] what not you son come
on floor it
beside me and my boys
I did it again
you know you remind me a lot of Andy
Barkley
he was a whiny little [ __ ] just like
you
did you kill him too more or less I
killed his childhood
and the truth is I killed you 25 years
ago didn't I Nika
we haven't been living
you can't call this living you've just
been on life support
time to pull the [ __ ] plug so you
never actually killed Andy Barclay did
you
what you know it's called completion
anxiety
it's very common in males
you are a male aren't you
oh I'm gonna kill you
I know I get that in 25 years must be
the slowest murder in history
I mean what are you waiting for a sign
from God
foreign
[Music]
oh you want to play [ __ ] let's
play
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
he made the funniest face when I drilled
him did you see the steam when I sliced
open his guts I never felt so alive yeah
well you've been alive for like two
minutes
welcome to the call pal thanks you guys
are the best right now I'm gonna go kill
Andy no I want to kill Andy I earned it
I've been through a lot today you got to
suck titty today look what happened to
me hello look at my hair oh [ __ ] you win
absolutely sorry pal you go [ __ ] them up
real good have fun
you guard the door kill anyone that
tries to get in right
[Music]